yes yes yes thank you yes sir thank you
yes sir
big bro terms of the shirt dude
really if you put those papers away we
can do okay yes sir I got something for
you today though I do I never have I
think that I can really get you I'll
take care you tick what is that figure
it out is it a flashlight it's too low
Zack okay thank you sir there's only
real between me and you
here you'll never find one like that
look at your design that's a rate okay
what do you up where you like CJ Sarita
I mean Ruby yes yes radio is this here
now that I'm if you like to know my
party stuff like this they all watch
Ruby what's what's going what's going on
in your head baby yeah some daddy sent
me some water
look yesterday you've got all over years
yeah makes the water so that's not a
whole different this is overall it looks
like a Mexico it's not white it's not
water like this it's water down to
Dennis so that's how they do it
so you kiddin always reroll your joints
you use your tobacco one more time
weird [ __ ] yeah use your ashes on I know
we jointly we processes it one more time
weird [ __ ] oh my my my standards all
over the world and I'm not just telling
you this to tell you I love you I love
you too
marriage there's no good buzz it was
cheating on me he hates me
together I am with you respect always
until the a disrespected first
relationships I belong with them but I I
have faith that God's gonna [ __ ] fix
all of it
romance is beautiful if you love the
right one and I found the right one but
it just don't worrywe you'll come back
uh my home I'm always a good mother um I
might be a drug addict but I had the
best mother so if I ever get that
opportunity to see my children again
which I will I promise that oh those
kids are absolutely beautiful
all of them
Ruby do you have children five so just I
have it your mama's raising it no I
don't know where they are but I do my
brothers think I'm safe this is a big
test we had to all take off this is a
bit of luck you miserable [ __ ] him
big intelligence just wake up dude but I
think hey I fixed when I could at this
moment I don't know I've lived through
it all I don't know it's God number one
I've seen the devil hey brother hey he
ranged two stories like this maybe
there's a story and a half okay with the
tale that was split in the middle with
like Spears it was where he shoot me me
and Biggie Smalls we've seen it together
CPUC the goddamn devil there he said so
what we could feel I said let me show
you
we're on the middle strand job all right
[ __ ] come get us if you but
we're right here [ __ ] here [ __ ]
what does that pick so I'm still here
really where do you sleep at night on
street think you've been a wonderful man
in this world thank you for uh going all
around the world keeping your mind open
because the clothesline
um it's say that but yeah it was even if
I give my kids and Steve I believe we
all stand is it soldier
discard [ __ ] made no work I promise you
you'll you'll make it I promise you
because he sits outside always had
thanks
your car will always get you bringing it
Ruby I think I'm how many years have you
been down here I have been in this part
of town about four months five months
yeah where were you before Skid Row
it's good no before that I was in San
Bernardino it's all started this all
started back in Jeff in the county jail
right here is the [ __ ] device see
this little [ __ ] dot on my head
that's the whole [ __ ] everything
right I know that I got cut it out I got
figured I thought I'll go do it today um
then all this will go a bleep um
sometimes I think people for locking
people down but then I don't know what
was in the inside so we got to get books
uh ones that you five get them to write
him right away
put him somewhere safe think you're
right book fortunately I didn't get your
information my brother Steve my are my
brothers I'm asking you to do it for
this man matrix in with my life thank
you
um other than that we're okay I love you
brothers you're the best
I'm a fight to my dying day to my heart
sun's beating for you guys thank you
you're my everything the huorchi
Lockwood thank you thank you see now
picture time right way take this with me
you